اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل ضابط وجندي في
معارك شمال ووسط قطع غزه وارتفع بذلك عدد
قتلى الجيش الاسرائيلي الى
178 منذ بدء العمليه البريه بينما بلغ
اجمالي العدد منذ السابع من اكتوبر الى
خمسه
جنود كما قال الجيش الاسرائيلي ان وحده
القتال في لواء المظليين انتقلت من منطقه
شمال القطاع وانضمت الى القوات في منطقه
خانيونس ومحيطها واضاف ان قواته هاجمت بنى
تحتيه من بينها نقاط مراقبه ومن ساط اطلاق
صواريخ مضاده للدروع ومخازن اسلحه وقضت
على مسلحين حسب
تعبيره وكان الجيش اعلن في وقت سابق مقتل
ضابطين من قوات النخبه خلال القوا خلال
القتال في شمال قطاع غزه احدهما برتبه
رائد في كتيبه الهندسه بلواء جولاني
والاخر قائد فريق برتبه نقيب في لواء
جفعاتي الذي يصنف من القوات الخاصه بذلك
يرتفع العدد المعلن رسميا لقتل الجيش
الاسرائيلي منذ بدء العمليه البريه في غزه
الى
166 بين ضابط وجندي كما يرتفع العدد
الاجمالي المعلن لقتلى ال الاسرائيلي منذ
السابع من اكتوبر الماضي الى